[Music]
among the many things being affected by
the governor's recent pandemic
guidelines
are court proceedings that's the topic
of today's la vegas now segment with
eric palacios
with kobit going on a lot of people
wondering if court proceedings
are going on as normal
that's a great question and a lot of
folks have uh pending matters
whether it be in family court or just uh
civil court or criminal court
and uh starting this week a lot of
courts have now closed down
again so a lot of hearings all the
trials are getting
postponed or moved forward what about
people who have been
arrested for crimes they're already uh
in jail awaiting a hearing of some sort
do those continue
a great question and yes because you are
uh detained you have certain rights that
uh things need to happen uh in a fast
track or a fast matter of time
unfortunately one of the results of
kovid
is a increase in divorces which means
there are child custody cases going on
what about those divorce proceedings
we've seen a lot of
of that a lot of an increment in
divorces and family matters uh child
support hearings custody hearings
uh those are still moving forward
they're
in a program much like zoom called uh
jeans so
that will uh still move forward you need
to talk to your attorney again to make
sure that you're available for that
you can participate a lot of times it's
easier if you go to your attorney's
office although
you can do it from your home and
everybody can log in
independently or individually uh it's a
lot easier at least
in our case in our firm we found it's
easier if the client is
uh you know sitting next to us uh then
it just takes one log in and it's easier
for the whole process to move forward
yeah what about things like traffic
tickets and civil cases
we get a lot of questions for that as
well if you receive your traffic ticket
during this year of the pandemic you
shouldn't worry
too much because most of the hearings
and
due dates are being postponed or moved
or moved
forward but you also cannot just forget
about it or ignore it which
often times happens
for more information give eric palacios
and associates a call at that number
702-444-7777